[Music]
you brought some some your to something
else now which is a product wigs wigs
yes that's way other my other big thing
is wigs no one is - believe it or not no
one is doing kids wigs wigs for kid wigs
for kids yeah kids don't usually wear
wigs yeah why not because they can't get
them yeah I mean if you if you want to
go to school and your parents won't let
you have a mohawk I can fix that right
now I'm told you brought some examples
with you upsetting the wigs at your
market for yes yeah okay do you want to
show us right and I'd love to okay then
beyond so take us through it all right
well um we've got some kid models here
it's the first one this this is Jimmy is
wearing the the peewee pompadour that's
the peewee pompadour that's fantastic
great job who's that
who does not want to go to school when a
beehive that's a VI that right beautiful
what is this here this is the man bond a
man this is very interesting because
this little girl is not old enough to
have grown hair this long right this
solves her problem yeah yeah I knew now
this is this as a contemporary one this
was not around this would not have been
a reference back in the day for me but I
think you can tell who this is Donald
Trump
[Applause]
would you really yeah um well they're
they're inexpensive really right uh you
know speaking of Donald Trump I have a
theory for Hillary Clinton that Hillary
Clinton simply showed up tomorrow with
Donald Trump's hair she would win the
election hands I really mean that I
really think if she put on that hair
people would go oh my God look at her
sense of humor she's making fun of
somebody I really think that's the key
if you're watching Hillary that's my
dinner yeah
oh she's watching all right this is
where she gets all of her latest news
and political information
you